it's labor day and we're here why are we
here we take federal holidays off we're
here because we're trading labor day for
an entire week off next week we will be
off all of next week
much needed for the staff and then back
with you for the debates and through the
election but good thing we're here today
because one of the biggest stories
of the last couple of months in terms of
its possible impact on the presidential
election broke over the weekend
which has now been quadruply
corroborated despite donald trump
claiming it is
all fake this is a story in which the
atlantic
broke a story uh claiming
that officials who were on a trip with
trump to france say
that trump called troops who died
losers and suckers and it is a hugely
instructive story from the perspective
of the evolution of damage control
because the initial story was just in
the atlantic and it talked about donald
trump repeatedly disparaging the
intelligence of service members
saying keep wounded service members out
of military parades it wouldn't look
good
and it even goes on to say that i don't
know if you remember that incident in
2018 where donald trump decided while in
france
not to go and honor the troops uh
at a cemetery near paris that it was
because of rain
and these individuals who have come
forward said it had nothing to do with
rain
trump was worried his hair would look
bad if it got wet
and he didn't think it was important
again to honor those
who were losers and suckers quoting
trump is saying why should i go to that
cemetery
it's filled with losers trump also
during that trip referred to a
conversation
sorry during a conversation referred to
more than 1800 marines
who lost their lives at bella wood as
suckers for getting killed now donald
trump came out and said it's all fake
trump administration officials came out
and said it's all lies
except then the associated press
corroborated it senior defense official
with first-hand knowledge of events
and a senior u.s marine corps officer
said to the associated press
the report in the atlantic is correct
white house continued to
insist it's fake and it's phony and then
cnn triply corroborated it donald trump
referred to fallen u.s service members
in crude and derogatory terms during
that trip
in november of 2018 to france
and then they said it's all fake and
then fox news quadruply corroborated it
take a look at this this is fox news
now john i've spoken with two senior u.s
officials who were on the trip to france
who confirmed to me
key details in the atlantic article and
the quotes attributed to the president
my source a former trump administration
official told me when the president
spoke about the vietnam war
he said it was a stupid war anyone who
went was a sucker
the president would say about american
veterans what's in it for them
they don't make any money the source
said it was a character flaw of the
president he could not
understand why someone would die for
their country not worth it
regarding the french trip to mark the
end of world war one according to this
former official
the president was not in a good mood
french president macron had said
something that made him mad
he questioned why he had to go to two
cemeteries why do i have to do two
his staff explained he could cancel but
he was warned
they the press are going to kill you for
this the president was mad
as a hornet when they did according to
this source when asked if the president
could have driven to the
ain marn cemetery this former official
said confidently
that there was not a security reason to
not to drive to the cemetery which was
about 40 miles from paris
quote the president drives a lot the
other world leaders drove to the
cemeteries
he just didn't want to go regarding the
president's july 4th military parade
planning
during a planning session at the white
house after seeing the bastille day
parade in 2017
president trump said regarding the
inclusion of wounded guys
quote that's not a good look americans
don't like that
regarding senator mccain the president
according to this source just hated john
mccain he always asked
why do you see him as a hero two sources
confirmed the president did not want the
flags lowered after mccain died
but others in the white house ordered
them at half mast there was a standoff
and then the president relented
that is fox news corroborating and
expanding the story
it's even worse than initially reported
actually based on fox news's additional
reporting
i'm starting to think the story may be
true and of course
it tracks completely with donald trump's
brand and a lot of this stuff he came
close to saying in public
including about john mccain the late
republican senator john mccain
who had been captured um
and held as a prisoner of war donald
trump saying he prefers
uh soldiers who don't get captured and
even tweeted about it i'll tell you
about that in a moment
the internal chaos that this caused at
fox news
fascinating because you had at one point
within hours
the opinion people saying this is all
fake and the news side
saying we've been able to independently
confirm
these reports and trump fundamentally
is not able to understand the concept of
someone doing something that's not
completely self-centered and greedy
he has an inability to do that and you
know when this story broke you had some
people on the left saying
trump is right these people are suckers
who the hell would join the military
i do think it's important to distinguish
between supporting the troops and
supporting individual wars
and what the military does i recognize
for example
that when george w bush took us into the
harebrained
misguided iraq war we didn't have a
draft in which
i could have been drafted potentially
um because we have a volunteer army and
people actually volunteer now
we often send them to the wrong wars we
use the troops
in disgusting ways for political battles
the way george w bush did uh but
nevertheless i don't think it makes
sense to denigrate
the individuals as the suckers we have a
military industrial complex that is the
problem
we have a deranged foreign policy
apparatus
and you know if if you do believe
that those who go and fight are suckers
tone down the military apparatus trump
has done the opposite trump
simultaneously brags
about making the military bigger than
ever but then says that the individual
troops are suckers and losers when they
actually go
and get killed and why is that it's
because trump
doesn't care about the individuals
in the military but trump is glad to use
the military as an institution for his
benefit when he can
it's very much on brand in fact could
this be trump's 47 percent moment
thinking back to mitt romney in the 2012
campaign
it's possible this you know a lot of
these things that happen
don't directly relate they don't
directly affect constituencies that
trump needs
if this is a case where if you look at
florida and the heavy military presence
in florida and florida being an
important battleground state where
it could determine it certainly is much
more likely than massachusetts or
california to determine the winner
of the presidential election disparaging
the troops in this way to the extent
that people will believe it
could actually make a difference and
again anybody doubting it it's been
quadruply corroborated
it tracks with things donald trump has
said publicly remember
john mccain not a war hero because he
was captured attacking gold star
family the khan family this is only
half a step further than what trump has
done publicly and in fact
donald trump once did retweet that
mccain is a loser
trump retweeting in 2015 an article from
fitznews
donald trump john mccain is a loser
now the stan the perspective there was
the election of 2008
but trump very critical of mccain
including for having been captured
and by the way this is maybe the most
interesting thing pete buudej has done
he was interviewed on fox news about
this story
and he used fox news's own confirmation
of the story
while on fox news against them take a
look at this
again i'm looking at the internet right
now uh fox news itself has confirmed
many of the details of this story so so
the real question is not
to me did trump do this it seems almost
certain that he did the question is
number one what else is going to come
out between now and november because the
atlantic is saying there will be much
more that this is only the tip of the
iceberg and number two will this affect
trump with constituencies he needs
like the military i believe that it
could
i want to hear from you i'm on twitter
at d pacman let me know what you think
could be the impact
of this story if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video